[Music]
thank you everyone for showing up this
morning on the very last day hopefully
you've had a great week we're here to
talk about supporting enterprise
applications with production great
kubernetes and this is a conversation
about the infrastructure or you know the
kubernetes on demand kubernetes as a
platform and not necessarily about the
applications themselves okay so
hopefully you were expecting that my
name is Tuan Winn I'm a technical
marketing engineer for Cisco I've been
with Cisco for two years I was actually
a transplant from an acquisition that
was clicker technologies and is now
Cisco Cloud Center okay so we're going
to go through a product overview the
product itself is called Cisco container
platform you may have heard of it
heretofore it will be CCP because I
don't want to say the long name right so
Cisco container platform CCP we'll go
through the product overview we'll
address some of the challenges with a
production grade kubernetes and how
we're solving for those those challenges
especially around storage and networking
and then we'll talk a little bit about
the hybrid cloud platform that was
announced or you may have heard about
this week and some of the the inherent
benefits of that reference architecture
ok so so the premise of Cisco container
platform is really to provide IT or the
the enterprise with a production grade
turnkey solution for consuming
kubernetes okay so some of the
challenges with kubernetes is automation
it's consistency it's integrating it
into the entirety of the Enterprise
ecosystem and so what we're doing is
we're we're taking code from upstream
kubernetes right I'll explain a little
bit about that and we're making it
easily deployable easily consumable
right and
what we're really designing for is a
consistent environment for kubernetes
across different clouds so it could be
on Prem as well as X cloud whoever the
cloud is you know I'll talk about the
partnership that we have with Google and
some of the the integrations that we've
already built into the platform but for
us we want to design a platform that is
hybrid cloud optimized and I'll talk
about that we'll talk about the
integration between kubernetes our
version of kubernetes and the ecosystem
and then we'll talk about the different
deployment models so today we have
integration into VMware because really
it's the most pervasive of the
hypervisors we spent quite a number of
conversations with our customers and we
were counseled and advised that really
the the need of the hour is for us to
deliver a kubernetes platform on VMs
right in the future will will have
integration into OpenStack as well as
bare metal workloads okay so one of the
ways that we differentiate ourselves is
that we make it easy for kubernetes to
integrate into the is right so for us we
have best to breed products hardware and
software around Sdn core and data center
networking VPN networking and then of
course storage with our hyper-converged
solution so we already have an AI a
Slayer that we've helped our customers
to design and then now what we're
putting on top of that is a kubernetes
environment that integrates into the
existing Aya's okay so a little bit more
about that you know 100% upstream we we
see our opportunity in innovation not so
much in modifying you know the native
API and code of kubernetes but the the
innovation for us is
to encompass kubernetes into the
ecosystem that is existing today in the
enterprise and so for us you know it's
it it'll be easy for us to deliver to
you with speed and scale the the new
versions of CCP whenever kubernetes
version changes right so if we're not
doing anything with upstream code it'll
it'll be easy for us to deliver it to
you faster right and then we're also
curating that version which means that
you know we're putting it through a QA
cycle and and testing and validation and
and making sure that when it hits your
data center that it's going to be
something that that is consistently
dependable across the platform okay so
speaking about the integration and and
about you know IT consistency we're
covering the day day 1 day 2 operations
right so insofar as we're talking about
setup the deployment of the platform
itself is software delivered it's an OVA
you just import it into V Center this is
something that is known to most IT
operations and then layering on three
different options for a CNI which is a
container network interface I will go
through that a little bit but from from
setup to consumption to integration and
management I'll show you how we we allow
users to self-service and and you know
deploy clusters from a management portal
and then also how we add day to
operations into a catalog into cloud
center which which is cloud center is
not a component of CCP but it is kind of
a centralized catalog for multi cloud
deployment
okay so CCP itself container platform
did GA in early May and previous to that
we went through a EAP cycle which is an
early access program I'm gonna explain
one of the use cases that we've been
highlighting because it really is the
use case that we are solving for but we
did go through an EAP program through
four or five months and then we have a
pretty aggressive roadmap for the
remainder of the year one of which is
obviously to integrate into bare-metal
and also to onboard more more
environments like OpenStack okay so from
an abstraction layer what you're getting
is a control plane and a data plane
right so the data plane is the
multi-tenancy layer which really means
that you know different users from
business from different business groups
or different development teams can go to
the interface of the control plane to
deploy their own tenants okay so the
tenants are color-coded by blue and
green right so you can see that there's
kind of a separation as far as the
default services that run on the tenants
as well as services that run on the
control plane right so the control plane
itself runs kubernetes so it's kind of
like kubernetes deploying kubernetes
right and and below that abstraction
layer is just the physical layer which
is the storage the hypervisor the
networking so we very similar to a lot
of solutions in the industry are using
Prometheus for monitoring Cabana as you
know an Elk's stack and then we're also
using graph on ax to visualize some of
the performance monitoring for
kubernetes
so architectual e and and both from a
logical and a physical perspective it
would look like this right so you you
you have a check stands for Hyper flex
so those basically would be your compute
nodes so on your compute nodes right if
you have a cluster of three compute
nodes you would have compute and then
you would have VMs that run the control
plane that would be the blue VMs right
so the blue VMs obviously would have the
same connectivity into let's say your
storage your layer 3 Network your core
networking all of those things apply and
then you have the green which represents
the tenant nodes or tenant clusters
those are also VMs right and of course
you can have a one-to-many meaning you
know many VMs operating on one physical
node which is the HX server right and
then of course what we're showing here
is that it's a it's a it's a well
connected stack whether you're talking
about the physical or the virtualized
environment right and it's self enclosed
you know it has access to you know a 10
to 40 gig bandwidth on the network layer
right and then upstream you know you can
well and you can do underlay or overlay
from a kubernetes cluster point of view
and then of course you know it will
integrate into your upstream layer 3 or
L 3 out gateways hopefully that makes
sense so one thing about the PGS which
stands for port group and VLANs these
are not a fixed right so these are not
static they're just examples of how
things would be connected and and you
know how they would be configured across
the entire stack okay so you know
integrating into the enterprise requires
a few things related to our back right
so we know that our consumers our
developers are different than our
operators and within the platform we
have a way to give you know those
personas
the privilege to do what they need to do
right so so developers usually don't
really they're not incentivized to
understand you know how to deliver the
service right they just want to consume
it which is the kubernetes side right
and so IT admins have a different
awareness or a different interest that's
to deliver the service levels to the
platform so that it can be consistent
and it could be highly available right
so from the point of view of the IT
admin or the consumer or the service
designer or you know the DevOps operator
or whoever it is we've we've got
coverage for the day one day two
operations as well as the different
personas that are interested in the type
of responsibilities okay and then I
mentioned that this is deployed through
VMware today so you know we also chose
that because really this is an and this
is an easy kind of non-friction seamless
way for IT operators today to adopt
kubernetes right that's really the
strategy behind the integration with
VMware okay and then this is really my
three screens to deploy a kubernetes
story right so this is the first screen
in creating a cluster right these are
the different options for the second
screen I'm gonna go through a demo
hopefully I'll have the time for that
and the third screen is basically
submission so what you see here is you
know the ability to name it to inject a
key that is known to the development
team different attributes about VMware
right so datastore you know network port
group the image name things like that
and then the size of the cluster right
so one thing about this is that once
this is deployed there there are several
things that the
the user can do based on roles to either
you know scale out or scale in this
cluster right so one of the things that
we're adding into the feature set is the
ability for the platform to auto scale
itself okay so now we're going to talk
about storage and we're talking we're
going to address specifically why
hyperflex
the hyper-converged platform that cisco
sells is important in this in this
relationship with kubernetes right so
you you probably are aware that within
kubernetes there's there's kind of a
native driver approach to provisioning
Peavey's or persistent volumes which
means that you know you can use the the
basic native driver it's nothing fancy
it just you know kind of delivers a
[Music]
volume to the containers but if you need
to deliver a kind of high i/o you know
persistent volume that also can have
some special attributes then you move
into the Flex volume framework right so
the specs volume dream framework allows
manufacturers to create their own
specialized plug-ins for kubernetes so
that all just described the Flex volume
driver that is specific to the HX
platform okay and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna go through how it actually works
although I'm not gonna really go through
the the deep dive right this is just you
know for instance if you have an ESX
server that's the middle green layer
right so by default the abstraction
layer of HX allows for NFS data stores
to be presented to ESX servers okay now
that is just typical shared storage the
VMS that are deployed through ccp
which are the kubernetes cluster nodes
they can both access the NFS which is
you know just file storage or file
shared volumes and then they can also
via I scuzzy via the i/o visor they can
access I scuzzy volumes now the
important thing about you know them
accessing I scuzzy volumes is you are
mounting an i/o level an i/o level
volume to the container so that the
container can it's it's a block level
device right so the container can
actually format that that volume and can
do special things to it and the benefit
yeah so the benefit is that on HX
because it is hyper-converged the blocks
of storage gets stored on two different
servers right this is very this is very
basic to how HX delivers a storage
replication right and then of course it
also automatically replicates you don't
have to do this the blocks of storage on
different nodes so it creates a
redundancy so that if one if one node
fails or if one ESX server fails then
kubernetes will bring up the containers
obviously and then the the containers
will also be remapped to their volumes
okay so how the benefits of doing this
with HX and CCP is that you'll be able
to apply some data retention policies
data protection policies and of course
you know you've got automatic
replication so that's inherent within
the platform and it's something that is
native to kubernetes you don't have to
do anything special you won't have to
install install special drivers because
of the integration with CCP a CCP node
will automatically have the Flex volume
driver installed every time you deploy
the the tenant cluster from CCP
okay and then from a networking
perspective you know there are many
different options underlay overlay
options when you talk about kubernetes
not all of these options are
standardized you know some of them are
pervasive across the different clouds
but the the unified approach to policy
design policy enforcement is one of the
challenges and and certainly a challenge
that we are solving with CCP so there
are three options for CN is when you
talk about CCP I'm going to go into the
first and the second option the third
option is calico that's the pervasive
one you know you can find it on gke you
can find it on a KS and eks also so it's
something that that certainly you know
you you can you can do research on your
own the first two are the ones that I'll
dive deep into so if you aren't familiar
with a CI a CI is our application
centric infrastructure which is really
just a fancy name for a Sdn solution
that is both hardware and software so
what I'm describing is you know the
ability for let's say a network
administrator or a network operator to
design policies that can be enforced by
the software or by the hardware right so
it's design and software applied at
hardware and it's effective to east-west
communication right so north-south
east-west is really where micro services
need protection and a CI is that for
both micro services and VM based
deployments so this is OBS based I
believe that it's a derivative of open
daylight cisco has had some you know
integration with OBS in the past this
integration the ACI CNI integration is a
little different but the there are
certain steps to do this if you had a
kubernetes cluster that was not deployed
by CCP so you you have the ability to do
this on your own if you have kubernetes
and a CI what CCP is doing is it is
automating all of the integration points
for you so you know there are a few
things that you have to enter into
configurations and then there's you know
ya know files that you have to bind the
CCP integration will do all of that
automatically and it's it's beneficial
to both the application architects as
well as the network administrators
because it's dynamic right it
automatically protects the pods that are
running in the fabric there are three
different models of protection so the
default model is a cluster isolation
which means that if you've got a pod
subnet right all of the pods across the
clusters are protected as one entity
right so in a CI it's called an EPG or
an endpoint group the the pods would
just be considered endpoints right and
then they would be protected as one
singular unit right inside the cluster
there's also if you wanted to annotate
the different the different namespaces
then you could accomplish a namespace
isolation which is not a cluster wide
you know then it would be a kind of
separation at the namespace layer which
is pretty unique when you think about it
you know things that operate inside of a
namespace or you know microservices that
are running inside of a namespace can be
protected both from each other as far as
you know the workloads and then from
other namespaces right so this is
treating pods as endpoints on the
network fabric and then of course you
can go as granular as protecting the
deployments themselves so each
deployment each you know replica of the
deployment would be protected by other
services in the deployment so that's
very very granular and then a CI from a
visualization construct makes it easy
for network administrators to see what
is happening and to also operate the
things that may be a little bit
difficult for the application developers
to to Express right so we don't express
expect application developers to
understand the network fabric the way
that a network administrator would write
but if there's a way for us to visualize
it which which there is a way for us to
visualize that the the filters and the
different you know contracts and and the
relationship that we establish in a CI
between what we call the consumer and
the provider which is the source and
destination then we make it easy for the
teams to collaborate and to troubleshoot
in one of those firestorms okay so one
of the other CNI options probably
something you may have heard of it it's
really a platform networking platform
that is utilized by service providers
it's it's called con teve it's you know
open source and it's been inside of
Cisco for a while our service provider
customers use it but it's basically a
user space you know it's it's a
networking platform that bypasses the
kernel uses the user space which means
that you know it depends on the driver
in order to to
propagate bandwidth across the different
nodes right so it's optimized because
it's not cereal packet processing its
vector packet pocket packet processing
and it's something that you know you can
probably get a deeper dive in if you're
a tied to a Cisco account or a Cisco
engineer it's I think a very intuitive
way to deal with container networking
okay so we have a plan to really follow
the the release cycle of kubernetes
itself so we expect that every major
release right one to two two to three is
is going to be very aligned to
kubernetes release cycles we're planning
on that to be quarterly you know
patching upgrades which is a you know X
dot X is is going to be on demand and
then minor releases will be monthly
right so we have right now a 1.3 that
was just release
1.4 is it will come out next month 2.0
will come out the next quarter so that's
kind of our plan for release cycles okay
and then obviously we'll have a
compatibility matrix of the different
parts of the ecosystem that we're going
to integrate into which is a great segue
into the hybrid cloud platform you may
have heard about this you may have also
heard about the G key on Prem so you
know that the the thing that we're
really focused on as far as the hybrid
cloud platform is the the hybrid cloud
deployment and lifecycle management
right so we know that there are new
roles DevOps you know service designers
you know people who work on modeling the
consumption all those different roles
and different responsibilities they need
to come into a
tool or a tool set that they can all
relate to right so all of their their
roles are converging and of course the
environments are expanding and also
getting more complex especially when you
talk about integrating those different
environments so the way that I've been
describing the hybrid car platform is it
is a reference architecture right so
it's very much like FlexPod have you
heard about flex pods in the past it's
something that you could build yourself
what we're doing is we are building it
integrating it and maintaining the
compatibility matrix for you right so
we're developing best practices what
this is is a reference architecture that
gets validated designs that gets updated
every quarter that that you know you can
either use the the validate design to
build it out yourself you know in a few
months or if you wanted to engage a
partner we've got plenty of partners
that have worked with us and and we've
also run a EAP a an early access program
for this very architecture so what that
means is that you know in the past
several months we've placed this
architecture right so rack and stack and
configuration into you know data centers
for eight of our our strategic partners
right and then we've had them go through
workbook exercises and kind of validate
the solution stack as well as the use
cases that we're solving right so this
is that this has already gone through
validation cycles I'd say that we're
onto our second phase of the validation
but the the the reference architecture
is going to provide to you a consistent
environment and a consistent model for
deploying as well as for designing
policies and governance for both the
enterprise as well as the public cloud
okay and then this is one of the
customers that we've worked very closely
with so
I'm sure that all of you have heard
about sa P you know they have a heritage
in data warehousing on-prem they they
were seeing that data definitely was
being distributed especially you know
IOT data or sensor data that was being
processed by ml or machine learning or
just big data in the cloud right so
there was a preferential treatment for
like customer or sales data that had to
exist on Prem and then of course it
needed to be integrated with IOT data
that existed of course on the public
cloud in the public cloud and so they
created this data hub which basically
has kind of a server list data
pipelining you know part component to
the framework and then it has a runtime
that has to be delivered near where the
data is so that's kind of a short
summary of what they were doing with
data hub but the reason why they
partnered with us is because the the
data hub and then you know the framework
for the data needed to run on kubernetes
right and so you know kubernetes the the
data hub itself needs to be on prem and
we delivered ccp for them to meet this
demand and so you could see that you
know they chose kubernetes because one
containers can be pervasive across the
different cloud platforms and that's
their approach is you know they need
interconnectivity between the different
cloud targets right and they need a way
to provide you know secure transport as
well as just connectivity and and
overall you know policy for the the pods
that run ok you know still time to visit
us at the Cisco booth and then many ways
for you to engage with us I'm gonna have
time for a demo so it's very good and
then I don't know if you heard about the
cloud challenge right so if if you know
you are a part of a team that needs
immediate and impactful results you can
enter into the challenge you know other
than bragging rights right you can win
$25,000 of credits in GCP which is a
grand sum and then you can get CCP
license for a year okay so I'm gonna go
into the demo so okay so what I'm gonna
show you first is CCP and you can see
that I've got tenant clusters already
deployed now let's make sure because I
mentioned that there is a VMware
component I'm gonna open up VMware and
we'll see if we can visualize that for
you but one of the things that is that
is unique to CCP is that you know we do
upgrades right so it's automated you
don't have to get in line to it you
basically choose what what it is that
you want to upgrade whether it's the
control plane itself or the tenant plane
and then we do the automation for it
right so the reason why I mentioned
upgrades is because all of us who have
interacted with kubernetes knows that
when you kubernetes you know a couplet
does not suffer an IP change or it just
doesn't it doesn't suffer through it
right so if you change the IP then
you'll have issues with your upgrade
because the API server won't come up so
the way that we deal with this is to
provide a VIP IP right so the VIP IP is
assigned to an API server and then you
know the attributes of the existing
cluster are going to be retained when
you upgrade right so we give we give
network administrators and operators the
ability to define their own networks and
their own pools okay and then I
mentioned that we we today have
integration into VMware that's our
infrastructure provider we're going to
make this compatible with OpenStack and
all
so bare-metal in the future and then as
far as Active Directory is concerned so
you know we assume that our enterprise
customers already have an existing
authentication provider so you you'll
see that this is already authenticated
and then you know all you need really
here is just a distinguished name and of
course it runs over TLS you know
securely and then you know you define
which ad groups you want and then we
automatically query those ad groups for
the users and we allow them to log in to
CCP right so you know probably this is
kind of one of those table stakes but
certainly you know SSO and and mutual
authentication and and just integration
into an existent authentication provider
is something that is challenging for
doing kubernetes manually and then doing
it consistently okay
so we'll walk through that three-step
process that I was talking about right
and we actually won't deploy a cluster
because I'm gonna do it with an API
right so
okay so here we're basically choosing
the attributes of a typical VMware
environment and the thing about the
thing about the networking layer is that
you can choose let's say the Conte CNI
and you can still operate the Conte CNI
cluster inside of an ACI fabric so there
are a lot of choices it just depends on
you know the underlay and overlay
options that you want to choose right
and then all I'm walking through here is
just the different options that you have
right so we're going to keep this
standard and then the reason for the
user name is because will inject will
create the user name and inject the key
so that when the users want to directly
interact with the the nodes it's going
to be delivered by an SSH key and not a
password all right so all right so you
get all these options and then this is
basically that that was the three
screens and this would be the fourth
screen right so what I'm describing to
you is a reduction of the you know
complicated logic that initially you
know would apply to doing kubernetes on
your own right now imagine that you can
offer this as a Service Catalog to
multiple users when you do this
obviously you can apply a governance
model around that right okay so I'm
gonna go back and let's say that I want
to interact with this cluster right so I
have the option to upgrade but I won't
upgrade because I don't have the tenant
image for that I'm going to download the
token okay so we'll see here that's the
token name right
okay so what I'm gonna do is I so
basically what I did was you know like
in order for me to interact with my
cluster I have to run COO control right
in order for me to run COO control I
have to define at least a config file
and this is basically that config file
right so this is the representation of
that cluster that I saw in the the UI
right so what I'm showing you is is you
know a seamless and easy way for
consumers as well as administrators to
interact with the assets that they
deploy okay
so I'll show you that these are all the
different namespaces and if we take a
look at this I may be going through this
too quickly but it's basically the same
cluster that's what I'm proving to you
every control plane has a swagger
interface right so this is kind of the
design first approach to providing a
consumable platform right so you can you
can look at all the different operations
right and let's open it up and if you
haven't used postman before it's just
you know a tool that allows you to
interact with api's so I'm gonna get a
token
I'm gonna do a get for the clusters and
then I see you know all the different
clusters so I'm gonna do a create
cluster alright so hopefully you can see
that I'm naming at Google next 18 TVN so
we do not have a cluster with such name
and now hopefully we'll see that it
starts to show up right so it's gonna
take a while to provision more time than
we have but the point here is that you
can easily interact with it through
api's right so one of the things that I
wanted to show very quickly now again
this is the cloud center product that is
one of the pillars in the hybrid cloud
platform is not a part of CCP right so I
just want to make it clear that what I'm
showing you cloud center is not a
component of CCP but it'll show you how
you know it's it's it's one thing for a
developer or you know someone to just
interact with the cluster using coop
control right very very difficult for
you to apply a governance model around
it I won't let this distract us too much
so so basically what I was going to show
you is that cloud center is a multi
cloud application delivery and
application application lifecycle
management tool right so what I was
going to show you is hey instead of you
know instead of allowing users to just
go to kubernetes and do a COO control
command to add a new namespace or to
delete a namespace or to create sto or
to install the Service Catalog
you would you would develop these
different Service Catalog items right so
you would present them in the catalog
and then what you could do is apply kind
of a an AR back model to the privileges
to those assets right so only certain
people would be able to do it right and
of course because of cloud centers
agnostic kind of nature what happens is
you you only
have to develop that service once right
and then that service conceivably could
be executed on any of the environments
that Cloud Center supports right and if
you don't know about Cloud Center it's
it's quite broad in you know it has a
very rich integration ecosystem as far
as clouds are concerned all the public
clouds that you can think of as well as
many OpenStack variants and of course we
showed VMware
[Music]